real job fuck oh no no then November the
Joe Rogan experience train my day Joe
Rogan podcast my night all day
[Music]
you listen to Big C sound watching me
roll down by the trains past Chinatown
[Music]
oh shit
oh you got do that one yeah that was
pretty low I love that fucking song oh
really good dude I will drink balls no
but I can tell you know what you're
doing it's cool it's nice to see you're
hitting all the right shots I love to
smell phone smell what I smell pot oh
yeah I like that smell it's like I've
always liked not been into the high that
much but I'd loved everything about the
drug like the leaves growing at yeah
rolling joints I mean when I was younger
you know right
so fun yeah I'm a big fan I think it's
just a killer be different no ball look
perfect in the world
[Music]
just cool seeing someone who knows how
to play cool
I got Hansel appetizer practice with I
mean a couple doing will play logic I
see her but he looks kind of far did I'd
be happy to play with you yeah what do
you live I'm right now I'm living in
Yucaipa California you don't notice no
ha ha it's on the way to Palm Springs
it's kind of in the foothills and
mountains more of a mountain II kind of
vibe when I brought you out there um my
cousin told me about the house and uh I
like the idea that I can fit a regular
pool table in there yeah isn't it on all
the hot I've owned like three or four
houses I've never had one that had the
room that would accommodate a four and a
half by nine
there's always Saul ways you know just I
don't know what
Thanks yeah that's huge for me man
it's one of the things that I liked
about this office one of the things that
I was excited about with this office is
that I knew there was space for a table
I persisted for was nice and I said it
I'll just be fucking playing all the
time I'll waste my life okay this is a
great table to practice on the pocket ya
know I'm joy I think it's changed my
game a little to be running out like
crazy on your diamond yeah well I saw
also filling up hitting balls a lot more
gently I notice that some of the shots
you good job making just um it requires
more of you because they're so tight I
wasn't sure if that would be good or if
it'd be annoying after a while but I
definitely think it's good yeah I just
requires requires you to concentrate
more is the pockets are so brutal
we got to make the right choices to not
get out
how do you plan ten ball if you play
that that count I'm thinking ten ball
that's not supposed to count
I think it's Photoshop you're play call
pocket we'll just play what goes girl I
like swell okay
I think like ten ball I got to show you
the shot that this guy he showed me
something and I I've been here in CG why
they talked about it for a long time but
I've never tried it it's so bizarre to
me
I'll show you
iron not blast
that's a nice shot yeah roll
I think that's one of the coolest things
about pool is the fact that you're
trying to control just a couple
revolutions on a ball over it yeah it's
like that just a little bit up that's
what makes a game so insane yeah if you
were just a little bit Roma mad yeah it
was a perfect shot
breakfast
don't have to love this yeah you're
going dead straight
oh nice do you know what Mac's are
believe oh yeah good yeah ask your buddy
agility god that'd be a good guys doing
stretches from oh yeah good one
knowledge wise fundamentals are so
perfect yeah the way he holds acute when
he describes it's the repetition you
know the repetition but he says on the
same you know the same amount of time
you're between shots yeah focus
concentrate
[Music]